thank you
[Music]
alright so there's this uh Russian
Mother Russia is Christina ozturk who
lives in Georgia
uh which Georgia I think our Georgia oh
wait there's more than one Georgia yeah
there's a country oh the country yeah
the country of Atlanta Georgia
Country Grammar
um so her and her Tycoon husband
all right have uh talked about having as
many as 105 children wow a wanting to
wanted to I thought you meant like her
[ __ ] was [ __ ] beat up like crazy so
far they're only like have 22. what he
popped down 22 kids now it's a tycoon
husband there's a [ __ ] ton of money so
many of these children
as many as 20 in one year were birthed
via surrogate year so they just gave
eggs and his sperms yeah to a bunch of
surrogates I see they're playing a
different game a lot of tycoons do this
but without like one wife why do they
look Asian yeah they're trying to be all
Genghis Khan to be fair Russia is also
in
there's some Russian people Russian does
uh I believe so maybe some Kazakhstan
too because Russia is geographically in
Asia right yeah yeah and it's only the
West Side Russians that look white the
East Side ones look Asian as [ __ ]
yeah that makes sense he saw Russia plus
they got a lot of them though some of
them have that [ __ ] blonde hair blue
eyes but look super Asian kind of vibe
slash like looking hot almost vampire
also exotic is it looking yeah looking
yeah exotic but like also kind of
vampirish it's freaking sick yeah it's
like a vampire yeah it's badass dope
have you seen them soccer on people the
soccer line people they look like
soccerline what we call Eskimos they
look like them
but they're called sacraments like with
a big coat
yeah that's the only difference when
they ride reindeer They Ride reindeer
that's all we see of them it's like
Kenny's yeah they're all bunches
well uh the thing that makes this a
little bit more complex is that uh this
current mom of 22 has started to uh
share the nightmare of ordeals uh that
has come up since her husband golly
Pastor was recently arrested in a
special forces operation uh with a
Ministry spokesperson saying that gallip
was arrested over allegations of
falsifying documents and money
laundering and now I thought that's
normal that kind of Tycoon yeah but now
she's sitting at home with 22 kids
should have thought about that we got 22
kids she's how old
uh it doesn't say how old she is but
they literally have 22 biological oh
cause he's at the mother of 22. I
thought she was 22 years old mother of
22. 22 kids so far so now she has 22
kids her bank accounts are frozen what
the [ __ ] is she gonna do pretty much
right and the husband's not home go find
me I highly doubt he's gonna make a dent
in what she needs to do with 22 children
like oh great you're home please help
with the other 11 right
have to have helpers anyway right they
just can't pay
for nannies yeah only way to do it wow
they're cash rich though you know well
now her bank accounts are probably
Frozen just get it if he's in Tycoon he
knows enough to have money in other
areas that she can pull
like there's not tight accounts so she's
she's fine the only other people that
I've seen do this in the states are the
Mormons
they're fine dude but they they do
multiple lives though so I guess it's
not the same you know what all she has
to do once America finds out about the
story TLC is going to reach out let's do
a TV show
we'll follow you guys that's true you'll
get paid out it'll be like me me and 20
I do love this [ __ ] you know how they
got 23 in me it's 22 in me remember do
you guys remember October that's a good
time my mom was huge she was popping off
because of John and Kate Plus Eight yeah
I'm a big fan of these shows by the way
I know about this stuff did that make
you want to have a ton of chill no
[ __ ] way man you live through them by
watching it maybe it's what's that one
with the [ __ ] [ __ ] couple and the
[ __ ] Asian boy
you don't see that one the [ __ ] Asian
boy no no so it's like a it's like uh
you say [ __ ] no more it's a it's a
little okay I've never even living in an
Asian married it's little people married
right yeah and then they and then they
they adopted little people babies wow
Toddlers and it's them raising the kids
oh I know and then there's the Asian boy
there's an Asian boy it looks like Bobby
Lee and Steve's [ __ ] love child
Maddox Jolie no that's that's Angelina
Jolie this is probably just a ploy to
get him out of jail he's probably just
like I can't raise my kids now let him
out
please I mean I think she's trying
because there ain't no way that this
dude was helping out she's definitely
probably trying to get some financial
help regardless uh but either way they
had revealed Christina Gallup revealed
last year how they spent 163
000 on surrogacy in order to have 20
babies together in just a single year
since then they were all born the same
year 20 of them yeah you think it would
be more expensive for those that's like
the price for one out here yeah I don't
know if they're hooked up like The
Matrix like an incubator right next to
each other just like man me
and the baby has a decision you know red
or blue oh wow you want to go back in
the womb they said she got like babies
like a woman collects [ __ ] purses and
[ __ ]
this is crazy that sounds like a women
be shopping joke
yeah 20 21st is a lot you imagine I'll
hold this baby today shoe collection oh
dude that's too many babies I can't even
remember all the names they say they
shell out 79 000 a year on 16 nannies
who care for the children
that's a bargain yeah 1690s that seems
very cheap only 80g you could [ __ ]
name them all the dwarves and the
[ __ ] reindeers so we got Rudolph
deaths or [ __ ] Prancer all that and
you got Dopey and [ __ ] smiley and
it's like a whole group and you still
have more names you have less people in
the cast of Love Actually
can we get a contact for these nannies I
know that's why it's got to be only the
money's Frozen that's why she's tripping
otherwise uh 4 700 a week on Essentials
for the babies like diapers includes 20
bags of nappies 53 bags of baby formula
or a pack of paper and stuff like that
yeah that's [ __ ] up they gotta like
freeze the account but then not the baby
account but why do they want 105 kids
I mean I guess if you're like a tycoon
and you can afford it yeah you got gold
is it 105 uh like a sacred Chinese
number the 105 stars of Destiny and the
there's like a as Bart that question man
I don't know it's like an ancient like
number of significance but having kids
is like oh that many is just so freaking
I Can't Rap how many is too many about
that and are you gonna be above seven is
a lot that should look like a
kindergarten dude that's what Elon Musk
is trying to do right but even Elon only
got like nine he's trying to have hella
kids right now elon's ethos though is
still talking about things like the
world population like declining
therefore everybody's part realistically
is to produce so he's got this weird
Asperger's ethos about it
he's having them like the old school way
too yeah with multiple wives yeah
but he's also Elon Musk you know but
what I'm curious about is I thought we
were overpopulated so why is his smart
only in some countries yes some
countries we don't have enough Good Ol
America apparently overall population is
declining that's good
not according to him well because of
economy wise it's not good
I'm there might be some just like
grander reasons that simpletons like us
can't process we can't be using
everything you know what I mean though
too many using things being able to
address the planet on a population
standpoint and you're like the richest
person in the world it's like you get to
you you're privy to certain topics
that's him maybe that's him warning the
rest of the world like hey according to
my research half of us are gonna be in
Mars in like 40 years so y'all better
get to [ __ ]
because you see the counter arguments
like we don't have enough resources
right so we should have less people but
I don't think he's about making the
world better I think he's about making
the economy better for the world because
it's interesting we live in a world now
we're in so much debt that we need the
economy to keep growing and if it
doesn't grow then we all collapse right
so like we're in more debt than we've
ever been in our whole lives in this
country right and so if this economy
doesn't grow it has to if it doesn't
grow we're theft because we need to
create more jobs you need to create more
we seem effed yeah we're pretty screwed
I think we're off dude yeah so we're
just like kind of bailing a sinking ship
economy must grow for us to survive it's
kind of crazy I wonder if he goes I just
want to be in Hawaii swim with turtles
right now you know does he ever have
those days where he's like
it's so hard like trying to fix the
world that's probably like how to make
it easier for turtles to swim you know
and it'll create like a device there's a
correlative data sheet that shows that
people who come from families with lots
of siblings end up more successful or
less
hmm because if you're just forcing
people to have more kids that may not
necessarily be better but if you're just
making everyone have at least one or two
maybe the resources can be allocated
justly where you could actually like you
know raise the kid correctly rather than
just have eight of them be like I don't
know what to do yeah I think for this
family they probably [ __ ] up the wrong
I think they're trying to break some
Guinness book a world record or
something crime doesn't pay man yeah he
loses bet 105 kids okay okay okay yeah
maybe he used to be a legitimate
businessman but then when he started
having 22 babies he was like
I need the retirement programs yeah oh
we get reached kid that's 2200 to grow
up I think the study came out that
showed that like China [ __ ] up you
know how like kind of [ __ ] up yeah
they're like oh we're overpopulated
right so they had that one one child
Rule and they started killing off all
the girls and she had that one child
Rule and then but they didn't take into
account that now people aren't really
having kids until like maybe if they're
mid or late 30s and if that some people
are choosing not to even have kids the
culture shift so now they're like
[ __ ] now we don't have kids we wanted to
limit people but now we have a
population Decline and like what the
[ __ ] are we supposed to do now is
swinging yeah and then there's like more
men than women yeah right so then like
there's gonna be my favorite Chinese
dudes with never having a wife
wow yeah
promoters hate that
go to the Chinese Club promoters gonna
do yeah he's covered you pay a cover you
pay a cover I hope Japan has more kids
I hope they're okay they're trying to
pay them to have kids and they're like I
refuse why don't they want kids because
it's a lose-lose situation for women so
most women don't want to do it in the
city so it's still hella traditional
where women is expected to do everything
but then it's modern enough to where
both couples are working so she's like I
gotta [ __ ] work a 40-hour work week
and then go back and do all the [ __ ]
kid [ __ ] where the dad could be a 1950s
dad and smoke a cigarette while watching
[ __ ] variety TV but when the kids
when the kids turn five they're out and
about they do whatever they want they go
out they go buy groceries they're
looking at that Japanese show with the
kids doing chores but they're on their
own now dude what's their five it's the
same thing for for the guys too the guys
are just like dude I don't gotta [ __ ]
pay for the whole family I just pay for
myself you know and then on top of that
I don't have to like do [ __ ] I can play
video games all day like it's like
socio-economically discouraged to like
married and have kids huh yeah so it's
it's like they're burdened way [ __ ]
more than our parents generation but
it's kind of the same here where like
it's hard to buy a house it's hard to
get [ __ ] like you got to be upper middle
class and above to have a decent [ __ ]
life so a lot of people are just waiting
to have kids until like they get better
education get better money all that
stuff and it's kind of like the same
thing but over there it's even worse
because uh it just doesn't work for them
to have kids this feels like a bummer
dude yeah
[Laughter]
diagnosis bummer
[Music]